– Sie können eine Ausbildung
beginnen oder studieren.
Ohne gute bis sehr gute
Deutschkenntnisse geht das nicht.
– Aber so wie ich das sehe,
haben Sie schon viel Deutsch gelernt.
– Herr González?
– Hm ... ’tschuldigung,
könnten Sie das bitte
noch einmal wiederholen?
– Ich habe gesagt, dass Sie für viele
Ausbildungsberufe oder ein Studium
gute bis sehr gute
Deutschkenntnisse brauchen.
– Ich hab gerade mit
B1-Niveau angefangen.
– Das klingt gut.
– Mhm.
Haben Sie die A2-Prüfung gemacht?
[Nein.] Aber ich hab einen A2-Kurs gemacht.
– Ich bin mir sicher,
dass Sie das können.
Aber ich bin mir auch sicher,
dass die meisten Betriebe
einen Nachweis über Ihre
Deutschkenntnisse verlangen.
Dafür müssen Sie eine
Sprachprüfung machen.
– Okay, dann mach ich
diese Sprachprüfung.
Und dann kann ich eine Ausbildung machen?
– Mal sehen.
Welchen Beruf möchten
Sie denn lernen?
– Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
– Sie sind sich unsicher?
– Mhm.
Gibt es eine
Schauspiel-Ausbildung?
– Sie können in Deutschland eine
Schauspielschule besuchen.
Aber da gibt es eine sehr schwere
Aufnahmeprüfung.
Niemand kann Ihnen garantieren,
dass Sie nach der Ausbildung
auch als Schauspieler arbeiten können.
Die Situation auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
ist für Schauspieler sehr schwierig.
– Hab ich schon gehört, ja.
– Sie können es natürlich versuchen.
Haben Sie denn vielleicht noch
andere Interessen?
Oder gibt es etwas,
das Sie sehr gut können?
– Ja! Ich kann Fahrräder
und Mopeds reparieren.